hey what is up guys mkbhd here and these
are my first impressions of the apple
watch now a lot of people got to go to
the actual apple event and get some
hands on time footage i wasn't cool
enough to get some hands on time with
the watch so i'll link some right below
that like button and also be showing
some in this video now people keep
asking me about this watch because you
know it's really exciting it's a new
apple entry into a new product category
wearable stuff which is really
interesting but after about a day or so
later
i i just have really mixed feelings
about it so for those who haven't seen
the apple watch was announced yesterday
alongside the iphone 6 and iphone 6 plus
which i'll also be covering and the
watch itself you know it's square it's
made of metal it's a little bit thick
it's not too flashy doesn't really stick
out when you look at it at first but it
has some very interesting software
features so for the hardware it's
actually three different versions of the
watch it's the apple watch the apple
watch sport and the apple watch edition
edition or something the standard apple
watch is a stainless steel body has a
pretty standard set of bands and a
sapphire crystal display the apple watch
sport has a lighter weight aluminum body
since you're going to be running around
with it a lot and these colorful rubber
bands and the edition is coated with 18
karat gold on the body and some fancier
bands so that's the clear fashion
statement one and all this hardware is
actually really personalizable which is
awesome so apple seems to be realizing
one size does not fit all here
especially with the new iphones and then
with this watch there's actually a small
size and a large size of the watch for
every variation so the small size has a
1.5 inch display and the large size has
a 1.65 inch display for reference the
moto 360 i'm wearing has a
1.56 inch circular display so right
about in the middle so you know people
with larger wrists tend to gravitate
towards the larger watch and people with
smaller wrists probably a lot of women
will want to gravitate towards the
smaller one naturally makes perfect
sense and the bands oh the glorious
bands i'm actually really happy about
the band so they have a bunch of
different material options they have
leather
metal rubber and they have different
clasps and buckle designs depending on
how simple or elegant you want it to
look there's a sport band that's sweat
proof and colorful there's the leather
loop that has freaking magnets like an
ipad smart cover it's brilliant i love
the bands they're really awesome but
what's really going to make the bands
important is the way they click in and
click out there's a really easily
removable standard that apple's created
for apple watch bands and that's going
to make the bands
huge you can already see third-party
manufacturers now making other different
materials and designs for watch bands
the same way they make different cases
for the iphone now it has a starting
price of 349 but that's just the base
price so
that's probably the smallest face with
the most basic band so i'd expect to
probably take more like 400 to 450
dollars for this watch which is not
cheap but here's where the mix of motion
park comes in the software
the knob there's a dial the knob looking
thing on the side of the apple watch to
interact with this new software the
watch senses that you're raising your
wrist and then activates the display
you see an organization of apps that
while new is somehow familiar
navigation is fluid and vital
magnifying content on a small display is
fundamentally important pause pause is
it actually is it really though like are
we actually going to be showing people
pictures
on our watch
instead of our phone
i don't know so it's called the digital
crown and it's this knob or wheel and
button on the side of the apple watch
that lets you move around inside watch
apps you can zoom and pan and scroll and
they make a huge deal out of this knob
uh even though it's still a touch screen
watch but it kind of reminds me of that
blackberry what was it the blackberry uh
pearl which had a knob on the side to do
everything but that's because it needed
it because it wasn't a touchscreen phone
i am really concerned though with this
whole knob thing on the watch first of
all it takes your interaction with the
watch from this
to
this or if your lefty one of these and
you know for if it's a knob is it going
to move around when i accidentally bump
it might it start switching through and
scrolling through things if i cross my
arms the wrong way is it going to scroll
and select something i don't really know
it's it's hard to tell because i haven't
actually played with it yet the idea of
it and the reason why there's a knob
there is so you can interact with the
watch without putting your finger over
the display which covers a lot of the
stuff and apple doesn't want you to have
to cover the display while you're using
it even with the knob there i think a
lot of people who get this watch are
going to be using it as a touch screen
watch anyway but that's the other thing
even though it has the whole tap versus
press sensitivity thing
the user interface is so much less
finger friendly than the other
smartwatch user interfaces if you've
seen my android wear smartwatch review
video you know it's nice and big all the
notifications you can swipe through very
very simple stuff even though your
finger covers the screen
this is apple's watch home screen if you
want to know what's happening here there
are a bunch of app shortcuts to launch
watch specific apps but i don't even
think i want to be doing that anyway if
that's going to be killing my watch
battery here's my bottom line if you
take the apple logo off of this and you
just imagine it was made by some other
company samsung for example and they
come out and say here is our
revolutionary new watch it's a square it
has a knob on the side it has this
really weird software and it only works
with our phones you might have laughed
it off the stage if that was a samsung
galaxy gear or whatever it was but
because it's an apple watch we're
willing to give it a shot just willing
to give it a try it's technically not
even out yet they have till the
beginning of next year when they release
it
uh and
they say they've been working on it for
years but i guess they have a couple
more months to get more revisions done
with the software and the hardware
but i'm not convinced yet smart watches
as a whole have a lot of convincing to
do i'll talk more about that in my moto
360 review which is coming very soon and
i hope to get my hands on the apple
watch soon and mess around with that too
but until then
very mixed feelings about this apple
watch and i'll keep my eye out for any
improvements or impressions that come
along in between now and early 2015.
until then feel free to give a thumbs up
on this video if you enjoyed it and a
subscribe button is also below if you
want to see more videos like this thank
you for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace